hi i'm ryan right and I am Jerry and I'm
Emily welcome two reasons to see we're
on a regular day we'd give you reasons
Tuesday for reasons not to see whatever
[ __ ] movie were reviewing that
goddamn day but today we're gonna do
some different tell us what are we gonna
do shut your mouth Jerry I want to do
this one we're gonna talk about the
biggest breaking news ever told in the
world this is the most important thing
that has ever happened Breaking Bad
season 7 Greenland yes it's about Jesse
Eisenberg and he's gonna be playing lex
luthor and jeremy irons bird Alfred
Pennyworth sorry pennyworth so let's uh
let's talk Alicia she apologized to me
if you ask me I think this probably
ranks up around the number one to number
three instance of weirdest [ __ ]
casting decision yeah number one would
be Ben Affleck as Batman yeah now you
got just yet Lex Luthor and Jeremy Irons
is Alfred Pennyworth what is happy I
don't know I don't know what Zack Snyder
Nolan are doing they're going for a
different interpretation that is so
different than it's not going to be
anything like what you've ever done it's
almost like they're trying to take much
beloved comic book characters and make
art house films out yeah definitely I
mean that's that's cool in some ways at
the same time it's if it doesn't honor
the original interpretation or anything
that we do know and love about them and
just completely make it 100 percent
different then I might have a little bit
of an issue with that I might like it
but at the same time you know it's kind
of a smart decision on their part
because I know a lot of people that
would pay good money to see Jesse
Eisenberg play lex luthor just for the
[ __ ] novelty yeah I love Jesse
Eisenberg though I think he's a
fantastic actor like everything I see
him yeah he did like the social network
everyone knows how great he was but then
I remember seeing it um I'm sorry I'm
Lee ever thought you know you were
talking that you start talking over me
so you [ __ ] talk that's what we're
gonna do you're making it Aquaman do it
do you have a problem with me Ryan cuz
if you do I could just leave right now
ha Ryan may be wrong
Ryan wrong I was just gonna say I think
there's a really far cry between Mark
Zuckerberg and Lex Luthor Oh was gonna
yeah that is but i'm thinking like he
has Rangers The Adventures of LexCorp
he's a fast-talking mother [ __ ] guy I
think using me cool seeing with a shaved
head might be a little extreme maybe he
doesn't maybe his hair in the first hour
and a half of this movie then he loses
it cuz they're my understanding and I
think what happened was is Superman
tried saving Lex Luthor and some
chemical thing went off which caused him
to be bold so that's why he hates him
cuz he's pulled I hate all bone okay he
made me bold he must die jesse eisenberg
and henry cavill or the same age are
they yes well they are a lot different
in size excited that much Henry Cavill
it's sexy Henry Cavill as he's a big
sexy man yeah he's pretty [ __ ] sexy
like he's got like a hairy body but it's
like [ __ ] he's probably the sexiest of
the Superman's this far though most
definitely yeah beats up writing route
space or what ever seen yeah i mean i
love brandon routh but be careful honey
thank you simple out yeah yeah hmm you
know but seeing Jesse Eisenberg and
there's a lot of people are like what
the [ __ ] but you know it's jesse
eisenberg this guy will just bring
something unique take to it and he's
gonna [ __ ] rock like I feel like
Jesse Eisenberg to bring like a sense of
humor to the performance like Kevin
Spacey did ah but a little different cos
he be of much faster talking Jewish
person I love Jesse Eisenberg and I
think he is a fantastic actor but at the
same time I do also think that he is the
same character in everything actors like
him they do play different characters
and they change it up we're so used to
actors like when they change like they
really change now you know it's not just
one guy Daniel day-lewis anymore to yeah
like Christian Bale got Johnny Depp
people who really change it up a ton
Johnny Depp is kind of a loan system
lately yeah Jeremy Irons I don't know
about that [ __ ] that's kind of
distracting me seeing like the Royal man
be Alfred the servant of Bruce Wayne
that one I can see a lot more what makes
more sense more sense than Jesse
Eisenberg as Lex Luthor women it's just
kind of like where the [ __ ] did you get
that idea guys you're really region left
field here Jeremy Irons is only weird in
the respect that it's like then you just
think of
hierarchy of acting it's like he's gonna
be waiting on denim yeah that's what I
mean Jeremy Irons is such like a power
image you know not like he's the most
powerful man in Hollywood but he has a
lot of pristine on the movies that he
plays and stuff spectabile yes exactly
exactly but I think Michael Caine was
too in a way I don't think on the same
caliber yeah probably not on the same
level you know you kind of prep people
with Austin Powers 3 I get kind of tired
of movie news like this because it's
like everyone loses their [ __ ] minds
over things like Ben Affleck as Batman
and and to a slightly lesser extent it
seems Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor you
know most of a lot of the superhero
stuff we've had lately is like what
Keith lit oh that was really good though
is this jim what aunt half of oh okay
yeah well well done you know once i'm
just kind of excited to see Superman
standing like two and a half feet taller
than Lex yeah I actually grew up
thinking Lex Luthor was black because of
the Superman cartoon so you know Jesse
Eisenberg's not black I'm gonna go he is
not I'm gonna indirectly quote a friend
of mine because somebody said this today
was like that's strange casting I'm
gonna wait to see how this one plays out
said no nerd ever like I wish somebody
would just take a minute to be like well
we don't know about you know I because
it's proven itself to happen before but
it just seemed like an awkward cast if
you die about it you got Henry Cavill
dead ass like [ __ ] Jesse Eisenberg
and then you got Jeremy Irons and that's
not that you'd see in a superhero movie
about Superman and Batman it's like
you're throwing a bunch of people it's
like you walked down to the freezer
section of your grocery store then to
the organic section then you bought a
magazines like everything is so
different in the in where they came from
that kind of sounds like my shopping
list right now yeah yeah kind of yeah
kind of like when you shop well maybe
it'll be all right it's like you got a
chef Henry Cavill who until now was
relatively unknown then you have Jesse
Eisenberg who's known for one very
specific thing they would have liked
prolific Jeremy Irons then you have like
not respectable until just recently and
it's kind of distracting to see him in a
Batman movie yeah Ben Affleck's itself
likes been respectable for a while you
did good
hunting I know the goodness he'll
respond first ever did she leave
remember the chronology but who knows
maybe zack snyder will make up [ __ ]
awesome movie lee that has it happened
once yeah Isle of Man of Steel actually
and I really like that zombie movie Dawn
of the Dead two chips the Eisenberg I'm
pretty excited for actually Jeremy Irons
I can't wait to see the most powerful
man be a servant and yeah this is an
opera cast but [ __ ] it we got no choice
but to watch it and we're gonna [ __ ]
about it till it comes out mm-hmm agreed
alright guys thanks for checking us out
talking about interesting stuff why
don't you go ahead and scroll that
comment box below and oh god why don't
you tell us what you think about jesse
eisenberg playing lex luthor and Jeremy
Irons is Alfred Pennyworth and then once
you're done with that once you come over
here click this button which I am told
leads to a playlist solely containing
these kind of news episodes so if you
want to see more news and trailer
reviews it's on the same playlister nuts
on the same playlist yet trailer you
corrected me last time for saying they
were the same place that trailer
reactions oh oh I hate the Internet
alright alright so go back playlist and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time a video of this
awesome caliber is out though subscribe
you're supposed to do it in sync up Jean
still ruminating over here it took three
videos to set me soon mini huh check it
out i'm gonna call your boobs rioting
Jerry that's fine yeah the important
thing is click on my boobs to subscribe
yeah clicking just here because
incentive to do anything that'd be cool
it was like touch screen like an iPad
what am I talking about like if you
could just touch your screen touch the
boobs are you would a tablet yeah then
just touch my beer I thought of such a
future doesn't weapon and I was like
it's been made many years ago we have
got to go pick up my sister it's already
happening okay pick up her sister you
gotta go pick up my sister cool gunner
boobs then we'll pick up our sister you
also has knowing she's 16 right oh no
you better not I will fly right the bay
content take him right in the face
chuck norris big Chuck Norris like Wendy
Wu homecoming warrior hahahaha that was
a cool